and now to our top story and sri lanka's
prime minister mahindra rajapaksa has
quit following growing angry over the
island nation's economic crisis and
ongoing widespread protests we can speak
to our correspondent minelle fernandez
who's live for us in colombo
eminel pressure has been growing on the
government to tell us more about what's
happened
so finally after weeks and weeks of
demands that the government
and the raj boxes that's president gutab
rajapaksa and his brother uh the prime
minister mahinda rajapaksa resign we've
had uh one of them that's a prime
minister handing over his resignation to
the president and resigning now this has
been
sort of been in the offing for a few
days if not weeks now where
the president and the prime minister
have been somewhat at loggerheads
trying to see which one blinks first
almost and we've just heard
that the prime minister obviously uh has
given him his resignation now there's
been from this morning there's been an
outbreak of clashes and violence uh in
an unprecedented manner we had thousands
of supporters of mahinda rajapaksa
coming in to his official residence
temple trees in colombo um you know to
sort of a show of force to demonstrate
that he still has support but
unfortunately where that went wrong is
there were a real belligerent lot he he
addressed this gathering of a few
thousand people and after that they came
outside that official residence they set
upon a camp of anti-government
protesters who had set up outside the
prime minister's residence they
assaulted people they set fire
to their tents they pulled down their
banners and then they started walking
towards the presidential secretariat
which was down the road that secretariat
has been sort of besieged and surrounded
for the last month by anti-government
protesters and the police uh even though
they tried to sort of mount uh sort of a
defense and prevent the people they just
walk through the police and that's why
lots of people are critical they're
accusing the police of allowing these
people to come into clashes with the
anti-government protesters at gota go
village and they completely bulldoze the
village through the problem now is there
is violence because people as we have
been reporting for weeks and weeks have
come to the end of their tolerance so
this show of force is not being taken
lightly lightly as much as people kind
of bulldozed in terms of that number
we're hearing reports a number of them
as those supporters try to go back
to their villages and to their areas
those buses are being set upon by
members of the public by organized
groups people are being pulled out of
these buses because people are so fed up
they are not going to tolerate having uh
you know be set upon these
anti-government protesters so it's amid
all of this that we finally had mahindra
rajapaksa the prime minister's
resignation all right so the prime
minister is gone but his younger brother
is still president so will this
resignation be enough to satisfy the
protesters
put it this way it is highly unlikely
because at the time that the president
uh even at the early stages of the
protest uh he
had the entire cabinet resign on his
request he appointed a new cabinet of
pretty much a majority young faces of
new of new faces new and fresh mps the
protesters said look this is not going
to pull wool over our eyes we are saying
go to go we want the rajapaksas to go
and we want the entire government
machine to be uh sort of swept clean so
almost uh you know sacrificing the prime
minister mahinda rajapaksa for the
president's survival is not something
that's going to go down easily with the
protesters they have
honestly spoken again and again in
recent days and said nothing short of a
clean sweep of the rajapaksas and of
this government however
we'll have to see in the coming hours
how they react but just judging from
what they have been saying and doing
over the past month they're unlikely to
be appeased
all right minelle thanks very much
indeed for that minil fernandez is there
with the news at sri lanka's prime
minister mahinda rajapaksa has resigned